IT IS TIME TO PLAY...
WHISPER ME THIS, BATMAN.
WHISPER IS A VERY POWERFUL APP
WHERE YOU CAN POST YOUR SECRETS,
CONFESSIONS, DESIRES, CRUSHES
AND CRIMES IN MEME FORM WITHOUT
HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT ANYONE
EVER FINDING OUT WHO YOU ARE
UNLESS THEY'RE ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE WHO'S REAL GOOD WITH
COMPUTERS.
SO COMEDIANS, I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
A PARTIAL WHISPER AND FOR 250
POINTS I WANT YOU TO FINISH THAT
WHISPER FOR ME.
FIRST ONE --
"I ONCE MASTURBATED IN CHURCH
DURING A SERMON..." BLANK.
(BELL DINGS)
UH, MIKE PHIRMAN.
>> UH, I FEEL WEIRD SAYING THE
FIRST PART, BUT, YEAH, I ONCE
MASTURBATED IN CHURCH...
>> SAY IT.
SAY IT!
>> HARDWICK: WHY ARE YOU
UNCOMFORTABLE SAYING IT, MIKE?
>> SAY IT, SAY IT, SAY IT.
>> HARDWICK: LITTLE TOO CLOSE TO
HOME?
(ALL CHANTING): SAY IT, SAY IT,
SAY IT, SAY IT.
>> ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT.
>> JUST SAY IT.
>> GET YOUR HANDS UP.
HANDS UP, HANDS UP.
I'M NOT... I'M NOT.
>> JUST PL... JUST SAY IT.
>> WHY DON'T YOU JUST SAY IT?
>> BUT...
>> WE WANT YOU TO SAY IT.
>> BUT... BUT SAY IT LIKE:
(WHISPERS): I ONCE MASTURBATED
IN A...
SAY IT LIKE THAT.
>> CAN'T DO THAT.
>> SAY IT REAL SOFT, REAL SOFT.
>> JUST WHISPER IT TO ME FIRST,
THOUGH.
>> JUST GONNA MAKE A JOKE, I
DON'T DESERVE THIS.
>> HARDWICK: I'M GONNA-I'M GONNA
GIVE YOU POINTS JUST FOR
ADMITTING WHAT YOU DID, UH...
>> I DIDN'T DO THIS.
>> HARDWICK: BUT IF YOU WANT
TO... IF YOU WANT TO GO AHEAD
AND GIVE YOUR ANSWER.
>> I WAS GONNA SAY, UH, I ONCE
MASTURBATED IN CHURCH DURING A
SERMON SO THEY WOULDN'T THINK I
WAS A COP.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
THE CORRECT ANSWER WAS "SIMPLY
BECAUSE I COULD."
UH, NEXT ONE, "WHEN I SING TO MY
CATS I..." BLANK.
(BELL DINGS)
JEMAINE.
>> WHEN I SING TO MY CATS...
I DO IT IN THE RAIN.
>> HARDWICK: AW.
>> BECAUSE I MAKE ALL THE
PUSSIES WET.
>> HARDWICK: WHOA!
YEAH.
MM-HMM.
SO...
POINTS, AND NOW WE KNOW HOW YOU
GOT A GRAMMY.
THE CORRECT ANSWER WAS "WHEN I
SING TO MY CATS I CHANGE THE
LYRICS TO MAKE THE SONG ABOUT
THE CAT."
>> OKAY.
>> HARDWICK: NEXT ONE, "I
PRETEND MY PILLOW IS A PERSON
AND..." BLANK.
(BELL DINGS)
LITTLE TOO EXCITED ON THE DRAW,
THERE.
UH, JEMAINE.
>> I PRETEND MY PILLOW IS A
PERSON...
AND IT ACTUALLY USED TO BE A
PERSON.
>> HARDWICK: TAI... TAIKA.
>> WELL, I PRETEND MY PILLOW'S A
PERSON AND, UM, BUT I'M A
PILLOW.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
IT MAKES PERFECT SENSE.
MIKE.
>> I PRETEND MY PILLOW IS A
PERSON AND... GET DOWN.
>> HARDWICK: OH, GOD DAMN IT.
THE CORRECT ANSWER IS "I PRETEND
MY PILLOW IS A PERSON AND CUDDLE
WITH IT ALL NIGHT."
THAT'S SAD.